hi my name is adria burr and welcome to
my glamifesto for life
my daily mantra is get out of your own
way and this
is because a lot of the time it's really
about getting out of your own way
and approaching fear and different
spaces
and different experiences in the past i
didn't
really have the self-worth to realize
what i was
capable of doing but once i got out of
my own way
it was really amazing the people who
came into my life and my openness
for experiences and people and
relationships
and work and achievements and
self-growth
so yeah my instant mood booster is
dancing i manage my mental health by
talking to my friends being honest and
open i clap back at misogyny by not
laughing it off and talking to my
friends
the best thing i've learned from a
mistake is self-reflection
and curiosity the thing that makes me
most proud about my heritage
is my peers around me
who celebrate it as much as i do
my family back in ghana and my family
here
and my dad what fuels my passion for
activism
is my community language and this idea
that we can
reframe one's perception of mental
health that we can break the stigma
surrounding it
to break the stigma we need to be
sharing stories
that one can relate to that come from
different backgrounds
different cultures and communities
glamour means to me
self-expression personality
individuality
pushing boundaries what makes me feel
comfortable in my own skin
is surrounding myself with positive
energy people who lift me up being
in a safe environment that makes me feel
like i can be my best self
or even my worst self at the best of
times my biggest
inspiration i have quite a lot but i
would say it sounds quite general but my
community
and all the wonderful people that make
it girls talk wouldn't be anything
without their honesty
and their ability to put themselves out
there and share their story
and i'd also say all the wonderful
people that i've had the chance to speak
to on my podcast
they've continuously taught me so much
on all sorts of different
subjects they've given me a new language
to express
myself and my activism the quirkiest
thing i've done
in the name of wellness is i'm a mad
believer and great believer in
manifestation
so i have a lot of crystals i use pyrite
in my manifestation process and i write
lots of lists of things that i'd want to
accomplish in years to come
if my beauty cabinet was on fire i would
save
wonder cloud from rimmel because
it would be good for those evenings
where you need to add an
extra kind of vibe to something and
and it's easy to use as well which i
also love i would save
exaggerate lipliner because i think it's
just an easy go-to
and it's an easy way to make yourself
look good
without kind of having to put too much
effort into it
thank you for watching that was my
glamifesto for life i hope you enjoyed
it
and if you'd like to watch more glamour
videos go onto youtube
and subscribe